[Música]
bienvenidos una vez más a áfrica siete
días en france 24 este es un magazine
informativo 100% dedicado al continente
africano
yo soy liviana valència aquí damos una
mirada en profundidad a los hechos de
actualidad de la semana en la cuna de la
humanidad uno de los principales
sospechosos de promover y financiar el
genocidio en ruanda feliciano kabuga no
será juzgado por la justicia francesa
como pedirían sus abogados en cambio su
proceso será entregado a un tribunal de
la obra
el continente africano se acerca al
millón y medio de contagios porque hoy
19 y supera los 35 mil muertos hasta
ahora la situación en los 55 países
registra un nivel estable tenemos ronda
informativa con nuestros corresponsales
y el senado de kenia debate un
controvertido proyecto de ley sobre
salud reproductiva que podría legalizar
el aborto voluntario hay polémica entre
la ciudadanía
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días porque el
máximo tribunal civil de francia
dictaminó que el sospechoso de financiar
y promover el genocidio de ruanda
felician kabuga podría ser entregado a
un tribunal de las naciones unidas para
su juicio esto en contra los argumentos
de sus abogados veamos la historia
cuatro meses y medio después de su
arresto el máximo tribunal de
apelaciones de francia dictaminó que
felician kabuga será entregado a la onu
para enfrentarse a la justicia el
sospechoso de promover el genocidio de
ruanda fue localizado en un apartamento
a las afueras de parís en mayo había
estado prófugo durante 26 años con una
recompensa de 5 millones de dólares
estadounidenses por su captura
poco después de su arresto los
investigadores de crímenes de guerra de
la onu solicitaron que fuera entregado a
jueces internacionales de restaurant en
hendaya desde el 20 de mayo tenemos una
orden de arresto y una acusación
proveniente del mecanismo de la onu por
lo que somos la jurisdicción competente
para tratar este caso de eeuu estrés que
es los abogados de cabo gas de 80 años
habían pedido un juicio en francia
citando su frágil estado de salud pero
el tribunal dictaminó que no había
ningún obstáculo legal o médico para
evitar su traslado a arusha en tanzania
donde el tribunal penal internacional
para ruanda está desarrollando casos
pendientes en respuesta al veredicto el
equipo de que aboga ahora solicita que
su caso sea transferido a la haya
las familias de las víctimas del
genocidio quieren que comparezca ante la
justicia sin demora las primas de este
mujer la mayoría de los testigos son
ancianos cada vez más se mueren de
viejos
si tenemos un deseo principal es que
kabuga vaya a juicio en ruanda porque
ahí es donde cometió sus crímenes es
importante que se haga justicia en el
lugar de los hechos
el dictamen en la boca de frente a siete
cargos de crímenes de guerra por su
papel en los asesinatos masivos estaba
acusado de financiar y armar extremistas
junto además de la cadena de radio y
televisión mil colinas que incitaba al
odio y al asesinato de pueblos tutsis
cerca de 800 mil personas fueron
masacradas en ruanda en 1994 en sólo 100
días
y seguimos hablando de ruanda porque ese
es el único país de áfrica sub-sahariana
cuyos ciudadanos pueden viajar a la zona
schengen es una de las naciones de las
15 naciones que europa ha incluido en la
lista de países seguros ruanda reporta
hasta el momento alrededor de 600 casos
confirmados por el virus
los trabajadores de la salud examinan al
azar a los viajeros cuando entran en la
capital de ruanda kigali los conductores
de mototaxis transportan a decenas de
personas a diario por eso su riesgo de
infección es mayor y es necesario
controlar su temperatura
pues con todo esto es para tratar de
saber qué está pasando en nuestra
población que tiene el virus quién
podría estar asintomático y no nos hemos
dado cuenta y en general tener una
imagen de como el coronavirus está
afectando a nuestras poblaciones
ruanda ha realizado cerca de 180.000
pruebas desde el inicio de la pandemia
su sistema de rastreo de contagios ha
sido eficiente y es hasta ahora el único
país de áfrica sub-sahariana que se
considera seguro para ingresar a la
unión europea sin embargo los estados
del bloque tienen la última palabra
sobre a quién dejar pasar se ha tomado
muy en serio esta situación desde el
principio fue el primer país del áfrica
subsahariana en tomar medidas de
contención todavía hay un número
relativamente pequeño de casos por lo
que esto nuevamente es el resultado de
un esfuerzo significativo unido de la
red
pero los funcionarios de salud se están
preparando para un aumento de los
contagios
y yo admiro nuestra estrategia en los
próximos días es gestionar los casos que
realmente necesitan asistencia médica en
los centros de tratamiento de esa forma
podemos gestionar otros pacientes en
casa o en comunidades en las estructuras
que establezcamos estamos en la fase de
control de la epidemia hay medios que se
ponen en práctica pero es una batalla
diaria sin ver tal de toulouse
aunque ruanda todavía tiene un número
reducido de casos la gestión del
contagio transfronterizo es un desafío
el país extendido recientemente las
medidas de bloqueo en cinco áreas
cercanas a la república democrática del
congo después de que se reportaron
nuevos casos de coronavirus
pero para conocer la situación en otros
países del continente vamos a una ronda
de informes enviados previamente por
nuestros corresponsales desde marraquech
marruecos sofía català nos habló del
bajo índice de mortalidad en el país
marruecos es el segundo país de áfrica
con más casos acumulados de kobe 19
habiendo superado los 120 mil en el país
se registran alrededor de 2000 casos
diarios pero es importante tener en
cuenta que sigue siendo mayor el número
de pacientes dados de alta y también que
la tasa de mortalidad a causa del virus
aquí en marruecos es del 1,8 por ciento
muy baja en relación a la media
continental y también a otras partes del
mundo aún así se sigue manteniendo
vigente el estado de emergencia
sanitaria decretado hace 7 meses por una
parte sigue habiendo restricciones de
movilidad y otras actividades en grandes
zonas del país y por otra parte y entre
cierta desconfianza se intenta reactivar
el turismo se han reabierto las
fronteras a los turistas exentos de
visados y es que la crisis económica ha
golpeado fuertemente el país según
últimos datos oficiales en el segundo
trimestre del año se han perdido casi
600 mil empleos y eso sin contemplar la
incontable cantidad de puestos de
trabajo de la economía informal
sudáfrica ultima detalles para la
reapertura de fronteras aéreas el país
más afectado del continente permitirá
vuelos desde hace algunos países desde
ciudad del cabo nos informó nuestro
corresponsal esa link para ya está
sudáfrica se prepara para reabrir el
espacio aéreo el anuncio presidencial
sin embargo indicó que esto se limitaría
a ciertos países específicos y
seguramente se limitarán a países del
continente africano y esta apertura
indica la casi reactivación total de las
actividades en sudáfrica aunque se
mantiene todavía el toque de queda desde
la medianoche su aplicación de los
países más afectados por la pandemia
aunque su tasa de recuperación actual es
del 90% ya promedia de apenas 1000 casos
diarios en las últimas semanas
estamos aquí frente al suntuoso estadio
ciudad del cabo donde los últimos meses
cientos de pasajeros han venido a
abordar vuelos de repatriación buscando
volver a esos países y salir de
sudáfrica durante los meses de pandemia
y retiro ante el pico de esta epidemia
aquí en el país pero adicional al virus
del cobi 19 sudáfrica se enfrenta a lo
que internamente llaman el virus de la
corrupción se trata de malos manejos de
fondos desde altos niveles del gobierno
que el mismo presidente rama posada
reconocido era un fondos que estaban
destinados a la compra de equipos de
protección personal así como ayudas
sociales y esto ha socavado
profundamente la confianza que la
población tenía en el gobierno que en
las primeras etapas de la pandemia logró
poner métodos muy efectivos para frenar
los contagios
y el índice de mortalidad también está
por debajo de la media mundial en costa
de marfil desde abiyán hablamos
previamente con nuestra corresponsal
varían con él
es el 11 de marzo que el primer caso del
juego
fue confirmado aquí en costa de marfil
desde esa fecha aproximadamente 20.000
personas
infectadas con el virus casi tantas
personas se han curado hoy en el día hay
menos de 400 casos activos según el
gobierno desde el convencimiento de la
crisis sanitaria se han producido 120
muertes con el juego y 19 pondrá mente a
los catastróficos pronósticos de la onu
sobre el número de muertes en áfrica
costa de márfil vayan con un pago número
de muertes impares son de otros países
occidentales los expertos creen que hay
varios factores que explican esto unos
de ellos puede ser la rápida reacción
del gobierno marfileño segunda o ms
costa de marfil es representa menos del
2 por ciento de los casos de colitis y 9
más
y es que el coronavirus también ha
generado impacto sobre la economía
africana sobre el tema hablamos en
exclusiva con un keniata presidente de
kenia de nuestros estudios en parís
qué pasa con el costo económico millones
de puestos de trabajo perdidos esto ha
sido una pesadilla
pensamos de sar de sectas which is now
tenemos algunos sectores que fueron muy
golpeados como el turismo obviamente y
algunos de los sectores de servicios que
ahora se están recuperando de axxion se
fijan futilidad de ver hemos tenido
suerte en el sentido de que por mucho
que hemos tenido una recesión económica
en términos de las proyecciones que
teníamos para el año
nuestros resultados hasta ahora son
definitivamente mucho mejores de los que
podríamos haber esperado han huevos o
sin nieve novations of people porque
todavía tenemos un crecimiento positivo
tenemos algunos sectores creciendo y
también hemos visto innovación por parte
de las personas que se adaptan a la
llamada nueva normalidad especialmente
en las industrias tecnológicas
restaurantes cerrados que hacen entregas
a domicilio y cosas así
así que si hemos recibido un golpe como
cualquier otra nación del mundo pero
afortunadamente no ha sido tan malo como
en otros lugares o como nosotros mismos
lo habíamos imaginado
pues justamente el senado de este país
de kenia debate un controvertido
proyecto de ley de salud reproductiva el
objetivo es facilitar el acceso a la
planificación familiar y determinar la
legalidad del aborto voluntario
la planificación familiar es de difícil
acceso en kenia y por tanto la
prevalencia de embarazos no planificados
es alta 7 mujeres mueren todos los días
debido a abortos inseguros en kenia las
mujeres de esta casa han tomado cartas
en el asunto organizan clases de
educación sexual para las mujeres de su
comunidad algo quiera saber sobre el
ciclo menstrual maurín se interesado en
el proyecto de ley si se aprueba
otorgará a las mujeres el derecho a la
planificación familiar y el acceso a los
servicios de maternidad en los
hospitales públicos ella dice que el
estado debe actuar simplemente no pueden
asumir que las cosas van bien y sin
embargo en el terreno las cosas son
diferentes tienen que venir con una sola
voz y luego trabajar junto con los
promotores de derechos humanos y
ciudadanos preocupados para ayudar a las
mujeres a acceder a sus derechos
fuguet dea rights los grupos religiosos
se han opuesto al proyecto de ley y
quieran que se retire según ellos es
controvertido porque promueve el derecho
al aborto cuando la madre está en
peligro y da accesos a tratamientos de
fertilidad una encuesta nacional mostró
que el 85% de la población está en
contra de la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo favorecemos un
enfoque en el que el gobierno llama a
las partes interesadas y obtenemos un
proyecto de ley que es más o menos un
producto de conciencia que respalda la
vida y la salud y nuestros diversos
valores morales y culturales en kenia
value sin que quienes se oponen a este
nuevo proyecto de ley lo describen como
solo pro aborto
sus partidarios acusan a algunos
críticos de simplificar demasiado las
leyes propuestas para sofocar el debate
y finalizamos con música que nos llega
desde sudáfrica donde la joven artistas
o más yo si se destaca por sus ritmos
modernos y sus coloridos vídeos
musicales estas son las imágenes de una
de sus más recientes canciones tituladas
con a con las imágenes que fueron
rodadas una parte del limpopo y la otra
en los ángeles esta joven cantante
quiere mostrar que está rompiendo las
fronteras con esta buena música
finalizamos este capítulo de áfrica a 7
días ustedes pueden continuar con más en
nuestra página web plan 24 punto com nos
vemos más adelante con más información
quédense
esto es france24
[Música]
y